I want to talk about my favorite pot
smoking left-handed gauge you Barney
Frank he was on Real Time with Bill
Maher this past Friday and he sort of
came out of the closet in a new way
okay Barney Frank do you feel more
liberated being out of Congress oh you
must
oh absolutely I don't have to worry that
when the phone rings it's somebody who's
screwed something up and says it's my
responsibility to unscrew it although
you you know you were in a fairly safe
district you were not one of those
Congress people who have to worry about
every little thing you could come on
this show and sit next to a pot-smoking
atheist and it wouldn't bother you I
which punch smoking hey PS when you're
talking about oh you are liberated oh
boy I I would tell you no I regret I had
asked my governor will point me to a yes
senator I wish I had to and I was
looking forward to having my husband Jim
hold the Constitution not the Bible and
affirm not swear that I was going to be
right wonderful senator you would have
been a wonderful set of there man
you you an Elizabeth Warren both there
that would have been quite a team well
we can only dream alright there's so
much greatness there like talking about
rationality and sanity but what I think
is fascinating about this is Barney
Frank has been out as gay for like 25
years or something yet couldn't come out
as an atheist until he was out of
Congress I know this is right in your
wheelhouse so I'm gonna start with you
on this one is that is that the crazy
part of this that he couldn't say this
10 years ago felt that would have been
politically riskier well yeah I mean I I
wouldn't say that it's crazy because I
think that we're so used to this at this
point but this is what I think a lot of
it atheist kind of rights groups are
really pushing towards you know I talked
a lot about atheist issues and people
always ask me like why are you trying to
convert everybody or I should say
deconversion atheism is not a religion
as we know but I you know program D
program yeah but you know it's not about
that for me I don't care what religion
you are that doesn't interest me really
what it's about is is forwarding atheist
rights and we're we're still a group of
people who yeah can't get elected to
public office if we're out about our
about our lack of religious affiliation
and so this doesn't surprise me but it's
I mean it's good to see him come out I'm
really proud of Barney for being able to
do that he came out in a very safe space
let's be real and he came out you know
if he had done it while he was in office
I think it might have been more
impactful for the for the cause or for
the movement but I'm not going to
denigrate him because I think that it's
great that he did it anyway and he's
already had to deal like you said with
the burden of coming out early and I
mean 20 years that's a long time where
he stands with his atheism now is
probably where he did stand with his
homosexuality 20 years ago because back
then it was not easy it's still not easy
get elected if you're an out um
politician yeah well that's why I think
it's just such a great metaphor max I
don't know where you stand in terms of
merely you know I mean we're good
friends and we that's one of the issues
that we both are totally in alignment I
mean I think we need more ideas in
Congress for sure yeah I think it's
great it's sad that that he has to sort
of have this big you know dramatic
unveiling of his lack of a belief system
you know I think I think more of us but
is it lack of a belief system it
actually
to me it shows a belief system of a
higher order actually at least in the
public sphere because by saying well I
wanted to put my hand on the
Constitution not on the Bible oh this
country is run I'm pretty sure by the
Constitution or it used to be a little
bit for sure I mean I wouldn't call that
a belief though I think that you know
most people who are public officials
want to uphold the Constitution I think
that that's probably like the number one
platform that everybody runs on right
but I don't know I mean I I get
concerned when people talk about atheism
as a belief system or as a religion
because it really is a lot you know like
they always say atheism is a religion
like bold as a hair it's not it's no
religion it's ear religion yeah it's not
like a new Church of atheism yeah do you
think that someone like Barney Frank is
going to be given a longer leash on this
now because by being gay it's like oh
well we already think you're this like
radical left-wing gay liberal
Massachusetts do you think that this
sort of will make this easier net you
know he's also out of the the public eye
a little bit now the guy I mean he seems
awesome like he was super hard on that
Occupy Wall Street girl on the show yeah
if you watch it oh yeah he was
relentless on her I kind of felt bad for
out of point there were real parallels I
think between real time this Friday and
newsroom this Sunday with the occupy
girl going on live television and even
though she newsrooms she really held her
own on real time like much more than the
character on newsroom did but uh but
yeah he was pretty tough on her when it
came to a comment she was making about
police and in lower-income neighborhoods
but aside from that I think that what
you were just asking about you know he's
gay and liberal and you know big ideas
already drop ultra religious
conservatives a lump all that in
together anyway I think they see all of
those traits as being you know traits of
the devil and so I don't think they're
gonna be that surprised either they're
just gonna see that like maybe somehow
the democratic process is being taken
away bit by bit right we have atheists
in office so if it is traits of the
devil I like that now I'm guessing you
two are more than ready to vote for
someone with traits of devil do you
think America is ready to vote for
someone that just says you know what I'm
an atheist or at least I'm agnostic we
don't even have someone that even is
saying that I'm agnostic I you know make
my decisions based on my own rationality
and all that yeah I mean I like to think
that America is definitely ready you
know but I obviously you know I live in
California and I spent a lot of time in
New York one of these pot-smoking
liberal you know it is the
fastest-growing minority is people who
don't identify with any particular
religion I think we're close to like 16%
now which is a really big number it's a
really big number uh
but that includes people who are atheist
agnostic or just say you know no comment
I don't identify specifically with any
religion yeah that number though the 16%
that's that is so huge is that a problem
actually within the Atheist community
that there aren't sort of leaders at
least that I know about that aren't
pushing it in more of like a political
fashion I think it's a problem that we
don't have political action committees I
think will we do but but they're not
large I think it's a problem that we
don't have lobbyists but but it's not a
problem in that we are the whole point
of not believing is that there is no
organized atheist we have we have
American atheist we have these different
but related foundation by the way we
have Bill Maher and in Dawkins and
people like that I mean we do have these
organizations where a lot of people are
getting more involved for political
action specifically but but really it's
about having like a secular Alliance
it's about upholding the Constitution
and maintaining a separation of church
and state I think that's what's the most
important to those groups it's not about
like we said before D converting or
deprogramming anybody or bringing people
over to the Dark Age it's more about
making sure that our legislation is is
done in a secular way to kind of
preserve what the Founding Fathers
wanted when they first set out to write
the Constitution right so so here here's
a so final thought on this because we've
talked about we talked a lot about
atheism I sure we talked about a lot
about pot on this show is there some
connection do you think when is there
little danger in the way he did this
reveal by saying I'm a pot-smoking
atheist like this yeah I mean I think
that people that smoke tend to be more
sort of you know open-minded and free
associative and stuff like that which
might lend itself more to having
alternate spiritual beliefs or
what-have-you I don't know I mean I
think there shouldn't be a connection
the blood I don't smoke
all right well I thought we can prove
that there's at least one not
pot-smoking atheist there you go America